ein herzliches willkommen und grüß gott
hier aus der maria theresien kaserne
heute haben wir militärisch fitness am
programm und ihr wisst es bereits der
sold beruf des soldaten des einsatz der
daten hat natürlich ein großes maß an
kraft leistungsfähigkeit immer brauchen
aber auch eine gewisse
ausdauerleistungsfähigkeit die von
wichtiger bedeutung ist und dem wir
haben uns heute widmen im bereich im
militärischen es mit dem schwerpunkt
heute aus der bewegungen schnell
kräftige bewegungen und das wird das
kreislaufsystem was wahrscheinlich
vermutlich an seine grenzen bringen und
das ist auch gut so
heute ist da die nickel daher wird und
ich da bitter wir sind wieder für euch
da
wir fahren mit einem gemeinsamen
aufwärmen dass wir da schon mal
anstrengend aber keine sorge wir
beginnen ganz locker mit stand lauf wie
gewohnt einlaufen bewegen
auch jetzt gibt es das knie vorne
zuerst an hinten alle varianten immer
wieder zwischendrin einbauen
wir müssen schauen dass man in kurzer
zeit euer herz kreislauf system so in
schwung bringen
dass er dann leistungsfähig und gut
trainieren kennst kurz aus lockern
arbeitskreisen vorwärts armeekreisen
rückwärts wechsel eine nach vorn nach
hinten richtung wechseln und die nachts
wieder am stand jetzt gerne das tempo
steigern
das heißt es trinken braucht man aber
einfach mal eine flottere bewegung
aktiver werden gleich die hände dazu
nehmen manchmal gleich aus dem stand auf
einem boxer lauf
[Applaus]
und kurz aus lang radstand vorbeugend
arme kreisen beziehungsweise becken
kreisen in der vorbeugung geht schon los
richtung wechseln
und jetzt machen wir das was sie
eigentlich wollte oberkörper vorbeugen
und den oberkörper kreisen rotieren in
der vorbeuge eine dynamische bewegung
wie virtuelle aktivieren muskulatur
bereitmachen aufrichten wir gehen gleich
weiter hantelmann jumping jacks die
wehren seiten aber zeit lang verfolgen
wir bauen es auf wenn man mit 1 voran
zurück der wechsel und wieder zeitlich
genau und kurz auslagern kurz
ausschüttung halswirbelsäule kopf wenn
linke seite rechte seite linke seite
dynamisch hin und her wechseln so dass
man auch im bereich der halswirbelsäule
eine entsprechende vorbereitung da
hinein kriegen blick wendung nach oben
und nach unten und wir wollen in einem
halbkreis von der linken auf die rechte
seite und wieder zurück
ok nehmen wir die hände seitlich
hochpreis mann aus dem ellbogengelenk
oder im ellbogengelenk die unterarme
andere richtung hände zusammen
handgelenk kreisen richtung wechseln und
ein gameplay wieder die dynamik rein
dann bewegen wir uns gerne wieder
jetzt da wieder mitlaufen am stand und
ihr hört von mir ein staat und den stopp
und die fleißig trainiert haben die
wissen dass auf start wäre richtig
schnell mit laufen und auf stop läuft
wieder normal ist dem buch weiter
start stopp und statt
stopp einmal noch höchst schock noch
start-stopp kurz ausschüttung gehen wir
zum kniegelenk hände drauf aufs knie und
wir kreisen in eine richtung richtung
wechseln nehme gerade strom gelenkte zu
nehmen mit den zehn am boden kreisen im
sprunggelenk richtung wechseln seite
wechseln richtung wechseln und kurz aus
locker höchst mobilität einmal bitte
gerät stets am boden und die zehn nach
innen und nach außen bewegen kann man
beim aufwärmen in dem fall als
vorbereitungs übung relativ dynamisch
machen
bei einer gleiche anwinkeln links und
rechts zu boden bringen
der mann aus dem bereich hüfte und
unteren rücken mit dabei
aufstehen und jetzt schauen dass man
muskulär uns entsprechend vorbereiten
das heißt wir machen 4 x 7
ich wiederhole 7 liegestützen kniebeugen
767 rücken aufrichten geht's los
[Applaus]
blick ist leicht nach vorn körper ist
stabil und gerade voller spannung und
die position wechseln kniebeugen auch
hier beinachse achten und wie der
position wechseln
erkennen zurückschauen ergebnisdynamik
hineinzubringen 7 wiederholungen das
bringt von als sicher jeder zusammen das
kann man schon mit einem gewissen
geschwindigkeit und eben dynamik machen
um dann auf die belastung die jetzt
folgt auch entsprechend vorzubereiten
und die rhythmen übung
das ist die einzige dem man essen wo man
nicht mit voller dynamik arbeiten
sondern mit der kraft aus den
rückenstrecken arbeiten und wenn fertig
wir wieder aufstehen und wieder locker
bewegen
jetzt machen wir mal hampelmann wieder
jumping jacks und jetzt darauf
startsignal flotte und auf stopp wieder
normales tempo weiter start stop stop
start
[Applaus]
aus locker ausschüttung wir schauen aus
allgemeiner mal der körper in schwung
kommen ein bisserl ok spezifisch nur
springern noch und abbau übungen dort
zum vorbereiten und dann können wir
schon die belastung eingehen ihr könnt
euch natürlich auch wieder am stand
bewegen am stand laufen oder ihr
schnappt euch einfach euer sprung schnur
und springt mit geht los auch hier kann
man dann die dynamik wechsel schneller
werden langsamer werden
[Applaus]
25 gesprungene ausfallschritte links und
rechts im wechsel
dann haben wir die dynamik in den beinen
a drin und dann wir zeigen es geht dann
im wirklichen workout besser weil der
körper chat vorbereitet ist okay wechsel
sprünge fünf mal geht's los
[Applaus]
9 und 10
genau so aufgewärmt fühlst du dich dann
haben wir erst einmal den ersten
programmpunkt einmal geschafft haben wir
erledigt was man jetzt machen bis wir
gehen in 30 sekunden die übung durch wir
erklären die übung danach üben wir sind
30 sekunden das braucht man mit unseren
vier übungen wie gewohnt
und wenn man das erledigt haben dann
gehen wir ihnen das workout programm mit
20 sekunden belasten zehn sekunden pause
zweimal acht runden und damit ist das
also wieder vorbei er hat es einfach an
aber ich glaube es wird richtig
anstrengend werden nicht nur für die
nici und wenn herbert sondern natürlich
auch für euch zuhause erste übung verbis
als kleine änderung zum letzten mal wir
springen die bleibt ist nicht nach oben
sondern wir legt sich ein handtuch legt
sich ein stopp in eine haupt der
markierung am boden wir springen
seitlich über die markierung drüber sagt
doch mal bitte vorne gehen das heißt
darunter hände weg aufrichten seitlich
drüber springen und das ganze eben links
und rechts hin und her als kleine
abhandlung mit zeitsprüngen ich glaube
wir uns verstanden
kräftesparen armen oder durchschlafen
macht sich bereit
im zehn sekunden statt man mit den
ersten 30 sekunden die quasi das workout
vorbereiten
drei zwei eins los
[Applaus]
wichtig dabei beim springen beim landen
achtet dass die beinachse stabil ist
beim aufrichten und beim weggehen von
der übung immer mit rom spannung
arbeiten dann salz genau richtig dabei
fünf sekunden und diese 30 sekunden sind
natürlich zum einteilen ganz gut teil
aus dass sie weiß wie viel belastung
heute mein körper aus welcher frequenz
kann ich überhaupt springen wie schnell
wie viel übungen kann ich da rein
bringen ohne dass sie dann entsprechend
mehr ins system überlastet
zweite über der marke bei herbert ich
darf dich bitten einmal liegestütz
ausgangsstellung ihr habt eine saubere
position von schulter bis zum
sprunggelenk gerade und jetzt zieht ihr
dynamisch das knie nach vor zu brust und
das ganze im wechsel machte dabei das
becken gerade bleibt und dass sie einen
stabilen muskulär gesicherten rücken
habt ja das ist das wichtige bei dieser
übung wir starten das mit 30 sekunden in
fünf sekunden gehts los
genau ist das bei der nikkei am 1 90
grad verdreht zeit läuft das heißt
brücken gerade dynamische bewegung knie
in richtung brust nach vor und 30
sekunden als relativ anspruchsvoll
halbzeit geschafft und ihr seht schon
bei den ersten zwei übungen
wir sahen heute wesentlich mehr in der
ausdauer drin wie ihn die kraft das
heißt es ist so akute belastung für das
herz kreislauf system was nur zutaten
natürlich immer wieder abrufen muss
können sei es aus 30 sekunden durch
und wie gesagt da ist das atmen
das schnaufen sauerstoff zur muskulatur
bringen ganz ganz wichtig und essentiell
das heißt es wirklich nicht
vernachlässigen in welcher position auch
immer dritte übung stark sagt uns das
bitte vor eine halbe kniebeuge nach
unten nach oben weg springen
arme und beine kriegen wie ein stern
wieder landen und runter in die
kniebeuge so einfach aus wenn man es
kann
wo wir zusammen durch 30 sekunden zeit
dafür ab jetzt
da hakt jetzt beim wegspringen darauf
dass wirklich eine gerade position im
körper hat und die beine schnell wieder
schließen so dass er kontrolliert auch
landen könnte in einer gesicherten
position fünf sekunden noch zeit ist
durch 30 sekunden vorbei die nächste die
dritte übung die körperlich belastend
ist herz kreislauf system ist gefordert
und man hörte man kriegt es mit
ihr kriegt das bei euch zu hause mit des
jahres auf 7 arbeitet ich muss mehr
atmen
der herzschlag steigt das ist genau das
wo man jetzt in wien 4 tv jumping jacks
das heißt der hampelmann dynamisch
gesprungen das heißt wer zögern sondern
wirklich 30 sekunden dynamischen
kampelmann springen wir starten wieder
in drei sekunden zeit läuft
[Applaus]
auch hier kann es natürlich variieren
mit vorwärts rückwärts springen das ist
überhaupt kein problem
wichtig ist nur dass hier permanent in
bewegung satz aus einer relativ hohen
frequenz so dass das herz dass das herz
kreislauf system nicht runter fährt bei
der übung sondern auf einem hohen niveau
stabil bleibt
fünf sekunden 321 vorbereitungsprogramm
erklärt programm schauen wir mal jetzt
kurze pause dann schlug noch trinken
vorbereiten auf die belastung die jetzt
kommt vielleicht wie gesagt werden auch
nichts dabei hat noch schnell ein glas
wasser holen und dann legen wir
gemeinsam los mit 20 sekunden belasten
und zehn sekunden pause das prinzip
kennt er bereits aber diesmal hat das
unterschied zum letzten mal keine
kraftübungen sondern ausdauerübungen
dort wo ich wirklich das herz kreislauf
system vor das auf einem niveau was
schon sehr anspruchsvoll ist
hast du einen tipp viele leute zu hause
wie teilt man sich die belastung als
richtiger einig
[Applaus]
also net die ersten drei sekunden oder
fünf sekunden so schnell arbeiten da sie
dann die restliche zeit glaubten immer
sondern das tempo so wählen so dass die
20 sekunden wirklich dynamisch und
durcharbeiten kann genau im zweiten
durchgang mit dieser name gas geben und
wie gesagt dann sah man da schon von
ganz guten weg
wenn ihr bereit seid wir sind definitiv
wir starten in zehn sekunden mit dem
ersten mit der ersten übung bis seitlich
gesprungen
20 sekunden belastungs zeit hohe
intensität viel spaß und durchhalten los
geht's ich werde natürlich immer wieder
versuchen euch die halbzeit dazu zu
sagen so wie jetzt zehn sekunden hat es
bereits geschafft dass man sich das auch
richtig dosieren und einteilen kann
20 sekunden durch station wechseln
position wechseln mountain kleinvach
zweite übung runter start geht los keine
zeitverzögerung und gas geben 20
sekunden lang achte trotz der dynamik
und des schnellen arbeiten sie immer
wieder auf eure position fünf sekunden
bleiben
[Applaus]
zeit ist durch wir wechseln zu den star
james vor atmen durchschlafen 21 sprung
los
[Applaus]
kontrolliert eure position kontrolliert
eure beinachse beim landen die tiefe
kein bissl variieren nicht ganz so tief
hinunter gehen ist asia anstrengend 5
sekunden und dritte über haben erledigt
das ist sicherlich eine der
anspruchvollsten übungen in diesem
durchgang für das kreislaufsystem also
nächste übung wird etwas leichter job in
jacks los geht's sie konnten nach drei
zwei eins und zehn sekunden sind wieder
zur kurzen regeneration und umbauen
quasi zum drüber springen bereitmachen
21 uhr los geht's halbzeit im ersten
durchgang haben wir bereits erledigt
[Applaus]
noch 5 sekunden und sei es durch
der martin gerber aus der liga auskennt
stellung kompakte stabile position
position einnehmen und los geht's und
wenn ihr merkt ihr kommt bereits jetzt
an das limit was die leistungsfähigkeit
daher gibt dann nehmt abidal tempo
heraus so dass sie das komplette werk
mitmachen kennt fünf sekunden zeit durch
zwei übernahmen im ersten durchgang star
james anspruchsvolle übung konzentrieren
zeit läuft das ist alles mit
körperspannung da ist als energie
dahinter
da gibt's kein muskel wackeln links oder
rechts vorbei da ist wirklich voller
druck in der bewegung fünf sekunden noch
[Applaus]
21 tief durchatmen hand und man springen
ist die letzte übung im ersten durchgang
danach machen wir eine satzpause ihr
habt euch verdient dann bereit und los
geht's
[Applaus]
zehn sekunden noch 521 pause jetzt
durchschnaufen bewegen an schluck
trinken lässt wirklich genügend
sauerstoff jetzt sind die muskulatur
eine das ist ganz ganz wichtig um
wirklich dann leistungsfähiger in den
zweiten durchgang gehen zu können
und wie gesagt jetzt hat bereits die
hälfte der belastung schafft die zweite
hälfte machen wir jetzt sagen kann in
falten legen oder muss ich ein bisschen
außer nehmen und genau auf diesem grat
bewegen wir uns jetzt mit einer guten
belastung nur mal acht wiederholungen
bei vier übungen und warum macht man das
um wirklich körperlich leistungsfähig zu
sein also wir trainieren genauso nicht
jede einheit aber immer wieder einheiten
wir trainieren mit leistungssportlern
wir drinnen mit den einsatz soldaten und
sie trainieren auch selber so und es
hilft uns weiter untersucht ihr euch
weiter dass wir körperlich wirklich fit
wird und da ich da was entwickeln kennst
ja ich habe die chance erster
durchkommen war in ordnung aber man hat
schon mit kriegt da das anstreichen
diese das so ist sein das ist gut so und
mit ihm was bei dir wie ist ein gefühl
schnell angefangen aber hat es passt
ok also grenzwertig okay aber gute
einschätzung zweiten durchgang noch
einmal zu träumen und in 30 sekunden
die browser vergeht immer super super
schnell in 30 sekunden legen war schon
wieder los mit dem zweiten durchgang
das heißt vorbereiten lässt die
handgriffe tätigen naseputzen zu trinken
und dann legen wir wieder los auch für
euch noch mal durchschlafen zweiter
durchgang positionen einnehmen fünf
sekunden bereitmachen 321 und übt man
erkennt dass natürlich auch wie die nico
unter herbert im einklang machen das
synchronspringen ist aber nicht
notwendig jeder in seinem tempo
ja das heißt das kann schneller oder
langsamer werden noch 21 zeit durch 20
sekunden vorbei position für martin
klein war ist die nächste die glaube
niemand war in 30 kunden geht schon
wieder los
21 von gas geben michael klein war die
zweite übung sechs verbleiben noch
[Applaus]
halbzeit fünf vier drei zwei eins grund
auf ja es wird schon ganz schön warm
also man sieht links und rechts von mir
der schweiß fließt bereit 21
los gehts star james halbzeit aber ist
jetzt genau das ist das wichtige wir
sind körperlich hoch intensiv arbeiten
um auch wirklich fit zu bleiben
und genau so geht es jedem anderen geht
es euch auch zeit durch doping 6 geht
weiter 13.21 uhr los geht's frequenz
hoch halten probieren so gut wie es geht
halbzeit durchgang nummer zwei ist
nämlich weit schafft ja in zehn sekunden
brauchen wir noch mal vier
wiederholungen vier übungen noch 5 3 2 1
und 10 sekunden position wechseln
vorbereiten wird bis mit zeitsprung nach
3 21 statt
[Applaus]
das schöne körperspannung halten
kontrolliert nach vorn zur seite
springen
ganz wichtig zehn sekunden letztes mal
pop ist eine beißen noch fünf sekunden
an geht's raus kommt 321 zeit aus
michael klein war wiederum nächste
position herunter liegestütz
ausgangsstellung einmal aktiv ein und
aus und schloss 2 1 und ab hier macht
das spitze zu hause genauso mit dabei
trainiert mit sieben sekunden noch
manchen klein bei
dann ist diese übung auch erledigt für
heute nach 321 durch sammer die letzten
zwei deutschlands und jumping jacks
bleibt über vorbereiten noch einmal
konzentrieren alles mobilisieren an
kräften die da sind in 21 los geht's
auch hier stabile position weg springen
und lernten kabine beinachse das ist
immer die grundvoraussetzung die muss
passen
nach sieben sekunden 5 nach 3 21 zeitig
durch letzte übung aber durchbeißen
dann hat man jumping jacks 32
auch hier wieder der wechsel nach vor
zurück möglicher wechsel auch im
weitsprung möglich immer wieder
dynamische position dynamische übung
fünf sekunden nach 321 dort sehr gut
gemacht die arbeit sehr gut und sehr gut
gemacht zu hause jetzt nimmt kurz 30
kunden an minuten durchschnaufen bewegen
der sauerstoff wieder in die muskulatur
lassen system runterfahren entsprechend
aus lockern ja was machen wir dann noch
kurz gemeinsam aber jetzt einmal jeder
für sich schauen dass er wieder so luft
kommt weil das war wie gesagt ein
hochintensives workout vier übungen
jeweils zwei mal gemacht in zwei
durchgängen woche intensive belastung
mehr brauche ich dazu nicht sagen
da braucht man auch eine gewisse
regeneration ok nickel es richtig
anstrengend ausgedrückt erscheinen oder
wo ist das auch okay er wird ja okay da
kommt schon mal wieder zu mir vielleicht
geht stand lass sie meinen körper runter
atmet tief ein macht euch groß also
jeder für sich seine atemtechnik
sauerstoff wieder in die muskulatur
lassen gerne darunter ein und ausatmen
hände baumeln lassen einfach
kontrolliert da das system wieder
runterfahren sowie beim aufwärmen beim
warm up das haben wir natürlich genau da
drinnen umgekehrt wir fahren das system
hoch dann haben eine hohe belastung und
dann fahren wir natürlich auch wieder
kontrolliert runter ok ich merke die
atmung kontrolliert sie langsam wieder
geht es einmal eine vorbeuge die arme
nach vorne und zurück schwingen
ok auch die beiname auslagern und
ausschüttungen kann man genauso machen
einfach immer noch voran zurück
schwingen und nachdem man so wie bei den
meisten unserer workouts den schrumpft
die bauch spannung immer wieder mit
dabei haben und auch immer wieder
kontrollieren was ganz wichtig ist für
euch zu hause braucht man natürlich
jetzt anderem ein kurzes mobilisieren
und auslagern im bereich wirbelsäule
lendenwirbelsäule das bitte einmal platz
nehmen und die beine leicht geöffnet ja
war hin und her kicken hüftgelenk einmal
mobilisieren noch jetzt an den druck
aber raus jetzt mache ich die bewegung
langsam zum regenerieren
ohne dynamik genau am anfang aktivieren
schnelle bewegung und regenerieren
langsam und entspannt
juni aufstellen leicht geöffnete
position und linkes knie rechtes glied
zum boden runter
ok und wieder aufstehen
richtig was machst du zum kunden am
liebsten was ist deine bevorzugte übung
ausgehen
[Applaus]
aber genau das kann man machen wir
können am stand ausgehen das machen wir
jetzt nicht für dich zum ausdruck kam
runde einfach am stand marschieren die
hände baumeln lassen ein bisschen revue
passieren lassen was habe ich jetzt
geleistet woche trainiert ja und warum
auch das klappe runter von herz
kreislauf system beruhigen genauso ist
es hell wird was machst du am liebsten
zum auflockern
ok auslassen ausgraben
dann macht man auch eine schwung übung
für die oberarme kommt zusammen die
vorbeuge dass die hände einfach links
und rechts hoch und wieder runter fallen
herunter bäumen aus lockern genau dass
man die belastung den druck wieder
rauskriegen und natürlich schief
weiteratmen genauso ist es okay leute
perfektes work hat von euch zu hause
danke fürs mitmachen hier aber danke
niki war wirklich hoch intensiven
belastungen gab man hat das gesehen und
wahrscheinlich auch teilweise gehört wir
sagen danke dass ihr mit dabei was wir
freuen uns ein verlässliches workout mit
euch auch morgen wieder und wir wünschen
euch noch einen schönen tag und wir
sehen uns morgen